柳老老和王熙凤之间有很深的冤远。单一红楼前八十回维句,柳老老两进中国府,接待人都是王熙凤。由于月独视角的限制,导致独者更多把这两次经历当作分析柳老老的珍贵材料,对凤结的解读则相对偏少。
布红君思认为,柳老老的分析固然重要,但曹雪芹借由柳老老这个乡下平婆子,将其当作打开王熙凤人品个性的钥匙,这一点也是不可忽视的。
柳老老一进荣国府的相关解读,布红君早已老生常谈,此不追数。重点谈谈柳老老二进荣国府,
也就是,坊间盛传的柳老老进大官员,柳老老能进大官员,手工当归王熙凤。
我们细独援助第三十九回,再结合人情事故,就会发现王熙凤对柳老老极与的关照是十分特别的。
这种特别是通过庞人生口式的侧面描写展现出来的。
第三十九回,平而参加完庞协演回到家,家里此时有四个人,分别是周瑞家的张才家的,以及柳老老和板儿。
布红君初读此处,还觉得有些奇怪,草雪琴为什么要在这里插住一个张才家的。
柳老老一进荣国府时,就是周瑞家的营灵祖孙而人进来,这次当然也是一样。
张才家的在这里发挥什么作用,有他没他有什么区别吗?
只看到平而归家,说起刚刚参加了史香云瓣的庞协演,张才家的奉承平而说,
我倒想着要吃呢,又没人上我,明儿在有人请姑娘可带了我去吧。
原来草雪琴通过张才家的这个校谈,按按江荣府内,婆子媳妇和压患们的矛盾埋伏下来。
因为奴才们中只有,冤养、虎破、彩霞、彩云等压缓,有资格单设一桌吃喜。
这也就暗合了第74回,超简大官员。
王擅宝家的在王夫人跟前,极力匪帮原内的压缓阶层说,
太太也不大往原里去,这些女孩子们一个个儿倒向受了风告似的,
他们就成了千金小姐了,闹下天来,谁敢哼一声,
不然就挑说姑娘的压头们,说欺负了姑娘们了,谁还单得起。
王擅宝家的匪帮,直接导致了秦文背念。
其后,营村的贴身压缓私奇也被年走。
周瑞家的带领几个婆子恶语相向,让她放弃往日父小姐的幻想,
直接将私奇脱走。
此例意识榮国府内,压缓婆子之力使矛盾的有利作证。
言归正转说回柳老老,
她这次来榮国府再次受到王西风的接见,
这从平尔和柳老老的对话中明显能看出来。
平尔英文,像是见过奶奶了,柳老老老道见过了,
叫我们等着呢,说着又往窗外看天气,说道,
天好早晚了,我们也去吧,别初不去城才是鸡荒呢。
周瑞家的道,这话道是,我替你瞧瞧去,说着已经去了。
王西风能亲自接见柳老老,可贵之处有三。
其一,联系前文情境,王西风当天是很忙的。
那天早上,史相银座东,学宝拆出物,
办了一场旁鞋宴,请家母吃旁鞋,上櫃花儿,
王西风一再尝刺后,
其后,家母等人离开,
史相银等人,开始起师设,做鞋花师。
王西风也随着家母一起离开刺后,
就在这空隙里,王西风还是接见了柳老老。
其二,柳老老一进中国府时,王西风并不知道他的底细。
再三让周瑞家的去问王府人,
所以客观来说,
王西风对出来炸道的柳老老客气相待,
有相当一部分原因是,信息不足所知。
他担心,柳老老万一是什么正经清起,
自己没处理好,会被王府人问责。
柳老老二进中国府时,
王西风在已经知道柳老老底细的前提下,
却还是愿意接见他。
甚至在去家母刺后之前,
丁主柳老老别走,在这里等着。
以至于柳老老担心天色晚了,
想要提前离开时,
周瑞家的还有专门去向王西风请示。
其三,柳老老此次前来,
是给容国府送自家众的新鲜瓜菜。
这种所岁小事,王西风完全可以交给周瑞家的处理。
接收瓜菜并给一些打赏,
面子上过着去就行,
自己没必要抽出时间,
跟这个拐了十八个湾的亲戚过多纠缠。
王西风绝不可能因为西汉这些瓜菜,
才对柳老老以理相待。
他在乎的是,
千里送俄毛,
李清秦一众的社交规范。
这是凤结最大的人格魅力。
所以王西风是一个矛盾体,
他是最势力的人,
又是最不势力的人。
包括后文中的行修煙,
王西风一开始以为他是行夫人的侄女,
自然人品新术也在下下城,
于是在安排住处时,
凤结专门把它安排在此林州,
跟假营村住在一起,
这样行修煙除了任何问题,
行夫人可以直接去找营村,
一切都跟自己无关。
但在后续的相处中,
凤结发现行修煙着实是一个好女孩,
援助写道,
凤结冷眼添夺,
修煙心性为人,
尽不像行夫人及他的父母一样,
却是温厚可疼的人。
因此凤结又连他,
家平命苦,
比别的子妹多疼他些,
行夫人倒不大理论了。
凤结原本要撇清关系,
到最后反承了他暗中疼爱修煙,
身为姑姑的行夫人,
反而不理不采。
在有第五十七回,
行修煙点到东医卖钱,
虚保拆物以为是越钱发放出了问题。
修煙却解释说,
凤结每月连日子都不错准时发越钱,
可我们都知道,
王西凤有挪用越钱放带冲时撕裤的钱科,
可他却并不延迟秀煙的越钱。
族剑上文所说,
凤结连他家平,
比别的子妹多疼他些,
并非一句虚言。
王西凤把这种关怀也给了刘老老,
他看人主要看的是品性,
而不是贫富,
凤结不是个一颗富贵心,
两支体面严的人。
在接见完刘老老之后,
又是他仪力促成后来的,
刘老老尽大官员,
我们来看原主中周瓊家的回话,
凭二等问怎么样,
周瓊家的笑道,
二奶奶在老太太的跟钱呢,
我原是悄悄地告诉二奶奶,
刘老老要家去呢,
怕晚了赶不出程序,
二奶奶说,
大远的,
难为他肯了那些成东西来,
晚了就住一夜,
明日再去,
这可不是头上二奶奶的缘了,
这也罢了,
偏生老太太有听见了,
问刘老老是谁,
二奶奶便会明白了,
老太太说,
我正想个机股的老人家说话,
请了来我见一见,
这可不是想不到天上缘分了,
诸君请注意,
周瓊家的像王夕鳳回话,
是悄悄地告诉二奶奶,
而年尽八十的家母,
如何能听清刘老老这三个字,
并且出言询问,
显然是王夕鳳回复周瓊家时,
并没有遵循悄悄地原则,
引起了家母的注意。
另外,
尽管家母出言询问,
王夕鳳大可以塌延疼色过去,
身为荣福管家的奉劫,
恐怕最擅长这个了,
可王夕鳳却一言一语,
回明白了,
让家母也对这位之前打秋风,
这次送瓜菜还人情的刘老老产生的兴趣,
在这个前提下,
刘老老进大官员才得已发生,
宗官这整个过程,
王夕鳳起到的作用是最大的,
而支撑他做出这种选择的,
是他品品人物不已富贵为具,
而已人品高低为先,
若不如此,
换作另一个爆发户之家,
恐怕可能让刘老老在门房将瓜菜放下,
就另其速走,
哪里还会这般接待?
故而,
布红金思认为,
刘老老的情商不然可贵,
但这种情商发挥的前提是,
必须预上荣福这样,
富而后里的珍贵组。
现实中有多少富贵之家,
皆是表富而礼不富,
空有富贵平囊而如富贵之礼,
这种礼非几代人的沉澱而不可得,
因此这些爆发户对待平寒之人,
多以居高凌晒之太世之,
若欲伤这样的贵族,
刘老老恐怕连大门都进不去和谈其他,
以代平之态度写贵族抵运,
意识红楼梦的蚊子深度。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,
我们下个视频再会。